sauf chez marcel annonce la télévision
alors
[Musique]
ouvrir ma boîte il va en sortir un
territoire
à la ville c'est la burqa ou le sésame
ouvre toi voilà voilà
agnès et toute la sympathique équipe et
pas face voilà vous habituer la
profession je suis
pas passé candide depuis qu'il est
retraité il a trouvé sa voie c'est le
jardinage alors on va toute l'année on
mange des légumes frais
vient d'amorcer moment y'a rien en ce
moment y'a rien ya
bien les fertois avec adresse aux
références corps et puis ce qui aurait
pu y avoir c'est le domaine paternel je
sais pas moi je vois que ça ce sont des
fraisiers miaoui ça oui ça sent de
travailler à la campagne on est
quand même à s'amuser fraises alors
voilà la loi qui s'est échappé le bus ce
que je sais c'est un buisson lui mon
écoute dans mon enfance dans le pyrénées
ont cessé ouvert depuis alors comme je
les reconnais faut pas exagérer des
buick est ce que c'est ça des carottes
et des carottes alors jardin
français du pc du père une rectification
c'était du persil
voilà alors des poires aux rockets il
enterrait des poireaux n'y a pas grand
chose
et bien ça c'est pas ce sont des
fraisiers ça mon petit ça ce sont des
fraisiers ça c'est un peuplier que la
foudre n'est pas à
voilà alors ça c'est c'la chef que nous
avons appelé très spirituellement
biquettes qui nous a été offert par mon
ami jean richard voilà tu lui laisses
moi j'étais ça donne
mais c'est un verger oui ça s'appelle le
verger d'ailleurs et quand je suis venu
ici car quand j'ai acheté cette maison
c'était tôt c'était en plein automne et
tous à crouler de friggit ya beaucoup de
pommes des poires le premier qui dit des
scoubidous je me fâche que les pommes
les poires des des abricots des pêches
des cerises enfin cette extraordinaire
c'est un régal ici d'ailleurs
ma fille a même toute une volée de deux
bambins de gamins plutôt à la traîne en
main et c'est assez rare gosses ici
assez remplie de go souvent des fruits
vraiment la garderie c'est ainsi un
ensemble de débreak qui s'appelle la
rencontre
c'est la vidéo buzz l'office il doit il
doit courir les chariots bien bilan de
sources soit fait le tour valenciennes
est encore la télé france
voilà alors ici vous allez voir entrer
dans le sanctuaire je ne sais pas si
j'ai trop droit de dévoiler sa bande
enfin ce n'est pas un secret cellule
cécile c'est le musée sylvie marsan en
d'autres termes c'est la chambre de ma
fille est envoyée
je ne sais pas toutes les folies à bien
il ya bien quelques exceptions la règle
georges brassens qui vient de temps
intéressé qui est un ami mais une photo
là là c'est le petit coin voyez en ville
hors essence mais alors là nous avons
sylvie sylvie en blanc sylvie andrée
sylvie avec brigitte s'il y avait qu'une
montre s'il vision la mer enfin tout ça
c'est sylvie vartan sylvie aja populaire
les collectionne depuis qu'on vienne à
je sais pas elle a une passion pour
sylvie vartan ya pas photo de son père
l'a au cinéma en l2 il avoir une ou deux
par là qui traîne mais enfin lors son
père elle le voit tous les jours des
civils
c'était un petit bonhomme pas plus haut
que trois pommes lésions boule de gomme
et qui rêvaient de voir
la mer
dessinant sur du papier le plus beau des
voiliers il vous laisse embarquer comme
au bon vieux temps des
corsaires
toi qui la connaît dis moi comment
qu'elle est la mère dit est ce que c'est
vrai qu'elle peut passer du bleu au vert
répond moi
c'est plus grand que ta baignoire que le
bassin du square que les temps aux
canards et ça ressemble au ciel
la mer
c'est bordées de sable fin de roches et
de pain et puis ça va si loin si loin
qu'à la fin
on la perd
elle veut me voir - oui mais si elle
veut voir la répétition de voir qui
revient lui mais le fils répète ça s'est
su aussi vite mais oui je suis sûr que
tes vêtements et à sa mère candy mais
tard dans la soirée et irak n'ont rien
de vivant après 23 heures la
voilà allez buvait un coup à boire
comment tu fais ça parce qu'à la télé
d'habitude tu vois à l'écran d'honneur à
chaque roue
et alors je vous ferai remarquer que
j'ai retourné l'étiquette je sais qu'il
faut pas faire de publicité la
trc du
et bien heureusement ce n'est pas le cas
tous les jours avant pourquoi
pas y tenir
vraiment petite mer 1
elle veut pas perdre son fils dans la
fleur de l'âge hall
la gloire mois
le fils et
puis c'est pas la gloire dont j'ai envie
c'est 6 mai dont la grille travail que
le travail je le cavac travail
maintenant c'est l'heure des
[Musique]